happy thanksgiving
happy thanksgiving to you and yours uh
you know i hope this is a time of year
where
you know where you can fill your cup up
you know sometimes i think my cup is a
pitcher
and i i i'll keep pouring
who wants a sip you get a sip you get us
if you have that ice hat
hell of pour i i'll pour a plant a poor
person who wants a cup
you know and and and i and i forget that
sometimes you know my cup's not even
full of nothing even in
and i'm still out there
just drip dropping on people
and so i got to remember to take time to
make sure that i'm doing things to keep
my cup full
you know that i'm putting joy in my own
in my own life so i can
so they'll have something to share you
know
and i got to be doing little thing maybe
you got to pet a little uh cat or
something
you know or bring up a damn jpeg of a
dolphin or something or you know or uh
you know eat a blue barrier do something
good like that
i'll even look i'll look on the video
sometimes soldiers coming home
and then they wheel out you know and
they they they wheel the guy the guy
climbs out of a uh
like a fake uh
easter basket at the uh pep rally or
whatever and you're like oh reginald's
home or something in the whole you know
everybody's crying and
and the team so usually they do that
that when the team is bad they do that
see
we need some damn war daddies over here
and sometimes you know it's a couple war
mommies out there you see a couple
you know if you see
you know
if you see a real long kiss and there's
four if there's four breaths and a kiss
baby that's lesbianism baby and this
you gotta enjoy that when you get to see
it so
um
happy thanksgiving uh some people don't
celebrate thanksgiving
i think it's canadians mostly
uh
i don't know who else maybe
canadians they should celebrate y'all
dude
canada's been shut down you guys might
as well start
celebrating it
there's nothing else you guys are so
scared of kova you don't even have i
think you took your door not door knobs
off
this locks only in canada
if you can't if you you got
they're back to writing letters
stationary
the stationary market
up in canada has just skyrocketed
you see ships of ink
going up there
yesterday you know
canada they
you they're not even allowed to
handshake
no hugging
don't you you'll see a married couple
just staring at each other until one of
them damn busts right out there
or you know really uh sugars you know
really drips out you know drips up their
britches
and they brits dripping out there in
canada because they the laws they've
gotten so coveted scared they
they just
even the snowmen no arms on them
no arms they don't want it nobody's
touching they're not doing none of that
none of that up in canada
what else oh the turkey farmer episode
if you didn't get a chance to check that
out check it out
you know it's nice to learn about the
birds that uh
that really are the mascot of
thanksgiving
you know it's really the the baltimore
raven of thanksgiving is the turkey
and a turkey baby that's god's tit right
there son that thing
you know if you put two hands on the
turkey you feel long enough somebody
going
somebody finding some milk
you could tell by
looking at a turkey that
that bird's hiding that last shay baby
you know
that by that bird
that's 98 degrees that thing's hiding
that nick leche you know what i'm saying
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one